yes it is gonna pass then well what many
people might wish that it will pass and
it would be nice together just thirty
thousand dollar years for free no matter
if you work or not it probably won't
pass and the government is opposing this
vote this initiative and at the moment
the latest poll shows us that people in
Switzerland seventy-two percent of the
people oppose this vote and having said
that well 30 thousand dollars might
sound like a lot this is just barely
above the poverty line in Switzerland
which is at 29,000 and five hundred and
something and so it would be a
misconception to think that you could
just do nothing and get 30,000 and have
a beautiful life but it is sure
interesting but yeah I mean this is
piqued interest in other countries
hasn't it I mean many other countries
such as Canada Holland and Finland are
looking this as as an experiment could
this take off somewhere well I think it
should be and that's what most of the
people agree upon that once witson is a
small country it probably still is too
big to to be a testing ground for quite
a revolutionary revolutionary idea that
hasn't been tested in smaller
environments before there are other
cities like you trashed in holland
ottawa in canada that are looking
closely to what switzerland is doing and
unless a miracle is happening the vote
will not be not passed and certain will
not be the testing ground for for it and
having said that there is a it
definitely triggered a discussion as
Switzerland is definitely not known for
doing let's call it crazy things right
and the votes just be
there and being discussed in a country
and Switzerland makes you wonder what
could happen